I mentioned you I was just at UIC and uh
Dana White is a huge Gambler he's a
blackjack Gambler and uh there's that
famous situation where he got kicked out
of a casino and the casinos do that kind
of thing when you went too much
so he he won some ridiculous amount of
money he bets like
I mean he plays like millions of dollars
on hands of blackjack it's insane and so
he won really big and he got kicked out
was it was he counting no no he wasn't
counting so counting in blackjack here
in Las Vegas is like the only game where
they actually can ask you not to play so
like basically if you're counting cards
yeah right you could potentially have an
edge in blackjack and there are some
professionals who do that but they get
caught pretty quickly and then they say
you can play craps you can play whatever
you want but you can't play Blackjack
here anymore no I think I don't think
Danny White is counting I think he was
winning a lot I guess they can uh claim
that they believe your con because how
do you really know if you're coming well
they easily they they figure it out so
basically they have an eye in the sky
and they can see so if you're varying
your bed size right so there's certain
spots where based on the cards that are
out let's say for example
the a lot of the twos threes and fours
and fives have been coming out so the
rich is the deck is rich in face cards
that's very good for the player right so
imagine you were betting 500 bucks
and then all of a sudden you up your bet
to two thousand or five thousand when
the deck is Rich they know when the deck
is rich in high cards because they keep
a counter themselves so if they notice a
player increasing their bet sizes when
the deck is good for them it's a
Telltale sign interesting I don't think
Dana White would be counting it's so
casinos don't kick you out if you don't
often kick you out do they ever kick you
out if you make too much money is it
playing millions of dollars they unless
they they would never kick you out for
making too much money unless they
suspect cheating because why would they
they have an advantage they want the
money back it's not like you go in there
win 10 million you're like oh no that's
enough for us what about if he was
talking [ __ ] the whole time I wonder I
don't think that would matter you know
because in the long run they'll get the
money back exactly